عمرو اديب هو مصطفى بكريه ردان على تغريده
نجيب ساويرس مشاجره بالسيوف داخل مستشفى
واسعه في الكويت تركيا تقاضي زوجها
ووالديها بعدما زوجها في سن السادسه هذه
الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
نبدا من مصر حيث دلعت حرب ساخنه اذا على
الانترنت على منصه تويتر تحديدا بعد اعاده
نشر رجل الاعمال صوره تظهر اعلاميين
مصريين يحملون الطبول منهم عمرو اديب احمد
موسى ومصطفى بكري اديب اعتبر منشور سوير
يحمل اشاره مباشره واتهاما له ولزملائه
بالتفضيل قائلا في ربه على ساويرس تطبيلنا
له اصوات وتطبيلك له ابراج ودولارات فيما
رد مصطفى بكري متهما رجل الاعمال بتهريب
اموال البلاد الى الخارج والاساء للجيش
مضيفا لا يحق له قاصده ان يشكك في مصداقيه
من يدافعنا عن الوطن على حديقه
[موسيقى]
وفي حادثه اثار الضجه واسعه في الكويت
افادت تقارير باندلاع شجار بين مواطنين
داخل احد المستشفيات مستخدمين لاسلحه
بيضاء قبل ان تتدخل قوات الامن وتوقفهما
صحيفه الانباء المحليه اشارت الى ورود
بلاغ لغرفه عمليات لوزاره الداخليه يفيد
بنشوب مشاجره داخل مستشفى الجهراء الواقع
غرب العاصمه الكويتيه وتم في خلال ذلك
استخدم سيوف وسكاكين مشيره الى ان القوات
الامنيه تمكنت من السيطره على طرفي
المشاجره وانتزاع الاسلحه منهما قبل ان
يتم احاله المتهمين الى الجهات المتخصصه
دون ذكر اي تفاصيل اخرى
بعد ما وافق على تزويجها في عمر السادسه
قبل نحو 17 عاما قررت فتاه تركيه مقضاه
والدها وزوجها ايضا لتتحول هذه الواقعه
الى قضيه راي عام في البلاد خصوصا بعد
تدخل نائب في البرلمان تقارير افادت بان
السلطات اعتقلت زوجا الفتاه اضافه الى
والدها الذي يتزعم جماعه دينيه مشيره الى
انهما قد يواجهان اضافه الى والدتها عقوبه
بالسجن مده سبع وعشرين سنه في حاله
ادانتهم جميعا بتهمه الاعتداء الجنسيه على
قاصر باعتبارهم مشاركين في تزويجها عندما
كانت تبلغ من العمر ست سنوات
قبل نحو يومين من نهايه العام نشرت مجله
فوربس تقريبا لها ذكرت فيه ان المليه
اصحاب المليارات حول العالم خسروا ما يقرب
من تريليوناي دولار مجتمعين خلال عام 20
22 فوربس اوضحت ان اصحاب المليارات في
الولايات المتحده خسروا وحدهم نحو 660
مليار دولار حيث انخفضت اسعار اسهم
الشركات التكنولوجيا بسبب ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده وارتفاع معدلات التضخم وتدهور
الاقتصاد مشيره الى ان ايلون ماسك لم يعد
الاغنى عالميا خسرا نحو 115 مليارا من
صافي ثروته خلال العام الماضي
وفي خبرنا الاخيره نشر موقع وولد بوبيليشن
ريفيو احصائيه جديده
لتعداد السكان في العالم العربي والذي
تجاوز 440 مليون نسمه الموقع اوضح في
تقرير له ان مصر ما زالت تحتل المركز
الاول في عدد السكان الذي تخطى حاجز المئه
والاربعه ملايين نسمه في نهايه 20 22
بزياده قدرها مليون و600 الف نسمه عن
العام الماضي في محل السودان في المركز
الثاني باربع
47.4 مليون نسمه والجزائر في المركز
الثالث بخمسه واربعين فاصل اثنين مليون
[موسيقى]